yeah so thank you very much for the
invitation i'm very glad to be here and
i will tell you about
some models that are very related to
what uh peter has just told about except
that the feedback we will consider is a
bit different so actually my talk will
be focused on the
um
to say it's a simple regret that is a
quantity uh the difference which is
between simple and
accumulated regret has already been
evoked
this morning
this afternoon in the first talk
actually i will come back to this i will
start by recording a few results on
uh
on standard regret on in-banded models
and then i will focus more specifically
on the questions that we have tried to
work on recently
uh at least you should uh listen to the
beginning of my talk since i will be
presenting a model that will be useful
tomorrow in uh in a robot
in robert's talk
so
at least
you should listen to this
so
one slide
after that
and then you do as you want
the model is well known but maybe not in
this community actually it's very close
to what peter was talking about
here
you have a k options uh the story i will
say is a bit different but it's kind of
the same thing you have k options among
which you have to choose
sequentially
these sequences are 1 2 k and
at each time you choose a option number
a you observe a reward from the arm
number a that is a drone according to
some probability distribution a new sub
a
and you assume that what happens on the
different arms is independent uh why do
our why do i call it arms it's because
this model
is famous as bandit model which refers
to the
situation when you go to
las vegas or casino and you have the
choice between maybe a
a row of bandit machines of
one-armed bandit machines and then of
course you would like to focus on the
ones that will give you those
the most
the more money and the you try each of
them and well you try to find the one
which has the highest payoff
the problem is of course that when you
choose one arm you observe only the
payoff of that arm
and the objective is
however to focus as fast as possible on
the arm that is that is the best
so
here we will assume that each
reward each arm is a probability
distribution belonging to some family
parametric or not if you're not
familiar with this model you can just
assume that this is a binary reward if
you choose some machine either you win
or you don't win
but well some other models have been um
studied too and what you can do is only
choose your machine the machine you will
use according to your past observations
that is according to the arms you have
chosen before and the rewards you have
had on these arms
using these arms
okay so why do people consider this
model it has had quite a
huge
impact in science for for decades
actually it started it all started in
the 1930s with clinical trials because
you can
uh imagine that your different options
are different drugs that you can will uh
give to some patients and of course you
want to save as many patients as
possible so each time
say you are a doctor each time a new
patient enters your your office you give
him one treatment you observe either he
dies or he doesn't die and of course
you want to save as many people as
possible
uh
so this is why there has been quite a
few works for for a long time on this
kind of models
recently
people are interested especially in
connection with recommend assistance
because it's a bit the same problem when
you you are a
web provider and you have a an ad slot
on the web page you can provide and of
course you want to provide each user
with the ads that he will click on with
the highest probabilities at the
beginning you don't know him you try
sports you try news
cars they don't know different kind of
ads that you get that you can provide
him and
you hope to focus as fast as possible on
the kind of ads that he will uh like
most
and there are other um applications that
we can discuss after roti if you want
but
usually
in this model people are more interested
in accumulated regret that's linked to
the story i just told you about the
number of patients you sell you save is
just st the sum of the rewards when the
rewards are bernoulli and if you want to
to maximize the st
so that amounts to maximizing the number
of times you uh you give
the the best arm the arm with highest
expected payoff
then this of course is equivalent to
minimizing the regret peter was talking
about the regret is the difference
between what you would have done if you
had known in hindsight which treatment
was the best one and what you will do
with your treatment
with your way of
trying the different treatments so what
you will do in expectations this is a
this is called the the
accumulated regret
and so while this is the problem there
are lots of strategies that have been
proposed to
minimize this regret some of
them are inspired by what peter was
talking in the about in the last talk
but
another one which has become quite
famous
is called the upper confidence bound
so the bad idea would be
just as before to focus only on the
observed performance of each treatment
if you just
rely on the estimate of the probability
of surviving uh giving a pill
that is the frequency of survivants
among those patients for which you have
attributed one treatment then this leads
to a very very poor uh strategy with a
very very high regret
you should not do this you should bias
your estimate and actually you should
give a positive bias to those
treatments that you have not attributed
much so far so you inflate the estimated
reward with an exploration bonus
that takes this form you can just
remember that it's
it's decreasing in the number of times
that you give you have that you have
attributed the treatment so far
so this is there are lots of reasons to
believe that
this strategy is uh efficient it has
been studied in a different uh
ways so far and maybe you will hear a
little more about this if you come to
robert's no uh stock tomorrow morning
that's not what i want to focus on yeah
so if a t is zero that means you have
not tried that r before that is infinity
yeah that's right so each at the
beginning you try each uh option
just to initialize this you can say the
index is plus infinity in that case and
so it will uh be priority
against all the other arms
yeah
um
what i want to
show to say is
well
this strategy works well you can try it
how well does it work what can we say
about the optimality in this problem and
the optimality properties in uh for
accumulated regret
in
classical bandit models is very well
known actually we can say
quite precisely how many times you will
have to play each sub-optimal arm and
this number is grossly speaking the log
of t the number of patients you will
have to see in your life divided by
an information term that is uh
actually a curveback live blood
divergence or more precisely an infimum
over uh killback live blood divergences
and this bound you can
obtain
uh by using changes of distribution
behind all these kind of arguments the
idea is to say that
well you want a strategy that will work
well
whatever
the bandit problem you consider so for
to make it simple just say that
you have bernoulli rewards and you have
two arms
so you can say that the parameter of the
first arm is p1 the parameter of the
second arm is p2
and
your
you want whatever the pair p1 p2 that
you have to face
you want to take the decision uh you
want to attribute in this part of the of
the parameter space almost always the
treatment number one and in this part of
the
parameter space almost always
the treatment number two
so the idea of these lower bounds is
always the same it's to say that
well the observations you make are in a
way continuous with respect to these
parameters
so
if you are just here at the border or
more precisely just uh here
in the other uh
part at the on the other part of the
border
then you would have to take almost
always the other decision you would have
to attribute treatment number two almost
always
but as i said the observations are
continuous with respect to that so
the observations you will have for these
parameters have a probability that is
not zero under
under this game and you can compute the
probability of observing exactly the
same thing here and here
and say that well this probability isn't
probably not overwhelming but it's small
but not so small and in that case you
will have to attribute treatment number
two very often so this gives a
contribution to the expected regret
under that value of the parameter that
is what you obtain in the bound of lion
robins further generalized by bernatas
and katakis
and
actually this is the right lower bound
since you can find algorithms that match
it quite exactly the two obtained
algorithms that match it with constant
one it took a bit of
effort but
there are strategies upper confidence
bound strategies for which the
confidence bonus is not
so trivial as in the plain ucb method as
you can
see from this formula the initial ucb
algorithm
was derived from huffling's formula this
is the way
this is a deviation inequality that is
not very well suited to all cases
uh much better way to obtain confidence
region is uh using uh for instance
empirical likelihood so what we
showed is that using empirical
likelihood based confidence region
then you obtain methods for you obtain
strategies for which the regret so the
expected number of times you play a
sub-optimal arm is exactly the this
formula is a bit frightening but less
frightening that way
is exactly
what you want the minimax term plus some
remainder terms that are for a smaller
order of magnitude
there's so much for
the accumulated regret
uh i don't want there's a lot more to
say there are very interesting
strategies thompson sampling lots of
things to say but what i wanted to
present today
is a slightly different problem the one
what you want to consider
best arm identification that is
the case where you don't
care about the patients you have in your
study
you just want to be able to save the
next patient the future patient which is
very important the president whoever you
want so you want to save this uh
additional guy with the highest
probability just this one and the other
one you can use them just to try as yeah
as you want
that is this time
for the presentation we will only focus
on a two-armed bandit model you have two
arms say you can imagine that they are
bernoulli if you want one of them is
better than the other in terms of
expected reward and you want to know
which one it is
so
you have to define a strategy that is a
sampling rule as before each time you
have to choose a new action given the
past observations that will lead you to
a new observation
but this time you also have to choose a
stopping rule when you have you say i
know which one i could i could give i
don't need any more patience patience to
try and then you have to choose a
recommendation rule once you have
stopped to say choose treatment one or
choose treatment b so this kind of
problem is
sometimes called a b testing a b testing
usually refers to uniform trials
sampling rules that is you try
as often the first and the second option
and often in uh in often yeah in a b
testing
the
time t the the number of trials t is
fixed in advance here we shall not uh
consider this
uh what i will present is a joint work
with emily koffman and olivier capez
that emily was a student of course
actually now on the job market and
well we wanted to
find the best way to address this
problem
but there are two natural ways to
two natural goals in this problem and
one is not more legitimate than the
other actually
the first uh these these ways to assess
the efficiency of the strategies
are both considered in the literature
the first one is to say you fix the
number of trials of
of trials you have to some deterministic
value t
and then you want to take a decision
with the probability to to make an error
as small as possible so you have the
possibility to choose which observations
is very related to active learning you
you have the possibility to choose which
observation you make but at the end you
must be very very good in designing the
best arm
and the second uh
the second way to assess the efficiency
of an algorithm is called the fixed
confidence setting this time
you want to make an error with a
probability granted to be smaller than
some parameters say delta
and then
you want to use as may as few patients
as possible so this time you have really
a stopping time here you can say at one
moment uh that you stop but then you
must be sure to take the good decision
with probability say us
larger than 0.99
so of course there has been quite a lot
of work on this problem so far still
we wanted to be able to compare these
two settings
as we we started uh well actually just
imagine now that you have uniform
sampling then this problem the fixed
budget settings amounts to a classical
test between two uh two hypotheses like
this whereas the fixed confidence
settings rather refers to
a sequential test
of this uh of
these two hypotheses and in the very
special case well you know the two
parameters u1 and mu2 you just don't
know which arm is mu1 and you knew which
arm is mu2
then it's well known that
you will use
fewer patients in the fixed confidence
settings and in the fixed budget setting
which is quite uh intuitive
in fact because here
uh you can observe patients one after
one and stop whenever you want so if you
want to stop with a uh
to to air to make an error with the
probability smaller than some delta you
will nee you will need
fewer patients that if you want to
assess the same probability of error but
you have to say in advance the number of
trials that you want to use you can
there's really a bonus for
sequentiality in this in this case when
mu 1 and mu 2 are both known in advance
and we wanted to know if this is still
the case for compound hypothesis that is
when you don't know you wanna and
neutral in advance
you remind us
this means just that you draw as many
times the first and the second arms you
don't use the weapon of the uh
of the
uh sampling rule you just say when you
want to stop yeah what you have to
choose then it's just a stopping rule
is only a stopping decision you're just
randomly formed
in the uniform sampling case which is
not the one where we focused on
especially but in the uniform sampling
case yes you can you just say when you
want to stop when you say i've got
enough i can save this uh this are this
treatment is much better than the other
okay
well
and so to be able to compare the two
settings we uh we wanted
to to define two complexity terms so
from the literature usually the
probability this will be no surprise to
anyone the probability of error behaves
as an exponential exponential minus the
number of trials divided by
some term here that depends on the
problem
and this term is naturally uh
interpreted as the difficulty of the
problem so the complexity is defined to
obtain this you take the limb super
still it tends to infinity of a mind
of this quantity it's very reminiscent
of
a of a large deviation
rate
whereas in the fixed confidence setting
the results usually state that the
number of uh
trials you need is proportional to
to log one over the
confidence you want times sometimes that
is a good candidate to be
termed a complexity term and this is why
we define the complexity in the fixed
confidence setting that way
and so we wanted to see okay we wanted
to see if
here again there is an ordering a
natural ordering between the two
complexities that will indicate that you
need fewer patients in the fixed
confidence or in the fixed budget
setting
and
actually to
to obtain results uh that way to
identify those complexities
you need two things of course you need
lower bounds and you need upper bounds
so the lower bounds
are
require some changes of variables
as in the accumulated regret case and
the upper bounds require to you to be
able to design strategies algorithm for
which you obtain approximately this this
efficiency
and
in order to
well i can't present all the way
the results in great detail but what i
wanted to show you is
a technical tool that is very useful for
the lower bounds actually these lower
bounds
they all rely also like here on changes
of distribution you can you try to
identify a confusing situation for which
the most confusing situation for for
your problem
and
as
in a standard statistic these changes of
variables in lower bounds
minimax lower bonds are often hidden in
the use of pin scales inequality say so
here's the equivalent for the banded
setting of pinker's inequality that we
propose is
this inequality from this inequality you
can recover easily lion robins and or uh
p are bernettes and katiaki slower bond
for the accumulated regret but it was
also the tool that we used to obtain our
lower bounds in the case of best arm
identification
and
uh it allowed us to prove this kind of
things
so
we
lower bounce on the
complexity term for the fixed budget
setting we obtained an in
an informational quantity that is
actually some kind of churn of
divergence so in cumulative regret as we
had said this is
library divergences uh
appear
in the case of best term identification
it's not
the same uh
callback library divergences that appear
but it's turn off information so what is
this so here if you display the
say
say you are with
bernoulli arms and so you take the usual
bernoulli divergence which is a p log p
divided by q plus
1 minus p
log 1 minus p divided by 1 minus q and
you plot
the
first marginal
okay p1 this is the same for
p2
then what is the information term that
appears you look at the point for which
this here you have p1 here you have p2
you look at this pista for which the two
uh the
kale divergences are equal and this is
this here so this
is
oh
uh
what
we called
k
star of p1 and p2
and actually the interesting phenomena
is that
it's not the same churn of information
that appears in both settings in what
case it's the first marginal that you
must use in your definition and in the
second case it's the second marginal
so in general
from the lower bounds that we obtain the
two quantities do not coincide
there's at least one case where they're
they completely coincide it's the case
okay i think
it's a case of gaussian variables for
which you have something that is
symmetric so in the case of a gaussian
variable this function of
p1 and p2
has a very simple expression of course
and then you find that
well you can have the lower bounds you
can have the matching algorithms and
the two uh well i directly skip to the
conclusion the two complexities coincide
and you have exactly the same
number of trials in both settings but
this will be my last point in the case
of binary rewards they do not coincide
of course there is not this property of
the variance is not the same everywhere
it has
large consequences
and in particular contrary to what we
felt initially and contrary to the case
of
two fixed hypotheses here
the complexity of the fixed confidence
setting
appears to be
larger than the complexity of the fixed
budget setting
and to identify them exactly is very
hard but we have been proposing some
elements of answer and some conclusions
that allow us to say that in this
setting
this complexity is larger than that of
the fixed complex of the fixed budget
setting which is
we found a surprising and a bit
remarkable result
okay
so thank you for your attention i think
you're running it really so if there's
one question maybe we can take it
yeah so um initially when you talked
about uniform sampling you said uh the
the way these two things relate it's
actually quite obvious
and then at the end you tell us but in
general it's the reverse
so isn't that somehow
no what was uh
what was remarkable it was not that we
used uniform sampling it's also that the
two uh parameters were known the two
hypotheses were known so mu1 and mu 2
were known when you don't know them then
it's it's a it's much more difficult in
particular what you
ask for the universal
for the university the universality of
the two algorithms is not quite
symmetric and actually this is uh the
trick this is where
you are much more demanding on the fixed
confidence universal algorithm than on
this fixed budget setting you want a
method that works whatever the
parameters of the problem so of course
when the
hypotheses are compound this is much
more demanding
here you just want in the fixed budget
setting you will just want to impose
that whatever uh
the problem
you finally take the wrong decision with
the probability tending to zero whereas
in the other case you want whatever the
problem the probability of error to be
smaller than delta so in a way
the
the fact that phase confidence appears
in this term
with this definition of a complexity to
be
more
to be larger in that case comes from the
fact that in this uniformity hypothesis
you are much more demanding
okay uh let's thank our again again
thank you